[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to week two of
the protest league as always my name is
Caleb Denby and I'm joined by the
wonderful Dorsett Derek Shawnee and
we're going to be covering the action
here today live on chess calm as I said
this is week two of the protest League
of course last Monday the st. Louis
Archbishop's faced off against the New
York Marshalls and actually had a very
strong showing scoring twenty and a half
or weight scoring ten and a half to five
and a half but then we get an extra
bonus ten for winning the match so as it
stands actually in the Western Division
our division we are one point out of
first place there are two teams tied for
first the Argentina Krakens in the
Chicago wins and we'll be looking to
catch them today as we face the UK lions
the UK Lions actually lost their first
match and so we'll be looking to make
that loss number two today I guess why
don't we take a quick look and see what
kind of format this match is actually
going to be taking place in there are of
course two teams of four players so both
teams have boards one through four the
time control is actually game 10+2 not
game in 15 that's a change sorry about
that
on the graphic and of course it is eight
and a half points to win the match so
there are 16 games total all four boards
play all all four other boards so you
need eight and a half to get the
majority and win the match of course
once you win the match ten bonus points
goes towards your standings in the
division yes of course I think why don't
we actually take a look at the parents
and we could talk a little bit about
that as well of course on our team
Wesley so is is playing this this match
here is on board too and he of course
has very very recently finished a game
in Tata Steel today I believe he had a
draw today so maybe it'll be a little
bit fatigued having just played a full
classical chess game but he's here for
us playing anyways on board - right
behind our board one Lenny a Dominguez
of course the I guess not so recently
now us player of switching federations
from Cuba it's happening
almost a full year I think glad to have
him on our team our board three is the
astounding Liam Lee of course former
world rapid champion playing on board
three for the Archbishop's this this
week and then our board for is a slew
student Nicholas Theodore oh of course
the title says I am but his feet I
rating says says you know some other
things as well I believe it's to 550
course as my comer likes to say the
strongest I am in the world which I mean
maybe it's up for debate but it's
certainly one of the contenders so yeah
Nicholas theodoro is our board for and
of course we see our opponents here
board one is actually at the bottom of
the list for the UK Lions Gawain Jones
board to the wonderful John Spielman and
then boards three and four are a couple
players I'm not super familiar with
actually we have max Burton brighter on
board three and FM Marcus Harvey on
board for and of course once again
titles can be deceiving
I think his feet are rating is above
2400 perhaps yes that is true the Marcus
Harvey even though he's on FM he has 24
12 I believe right and I am max past 24
91 so almost 500 so some deceptively
strong players on both teams perhaps now
I guess we're just waiting for the start
of the rounds we saw Lenny a Dominguez
actually playing some some warm-up games
here on lunch Escom against big fish
1995 who we thought was photo save maybe
yeah yes
Wladimir photo save so Lenny ain't
getting a little bit warmed up so the
the first week we were of course hugely
hugely favorite there is one notable
player missing from from our roster this
week in Fabiano Carolina which
unfortunately you know maybe he's
focusing a little bit more on Tata Steel
which is understandable but it gives
Nicolas theodoro a chance to show that
that he deserves to be on this team with
these elite players interesting to see
what he can do
what do you expect from Nicholas Seeger
to GM soon as soon as possible they have
to get the GM how about today in this
man well I honestly think he's not going
to have a hard time today because he's a
very good player he might sell the only
man said I would I don't want to say
worried about but maybe look more
carefully at is his right now he's the
first round with of course on board for
Nicholas is going to be facing the UK
Lions board one and the board to than
the so he is he's a hard schedule he
plays from the top down well is playing
board for for our team yes
and of course you know going Jones and
John Spielman or both you know chess
legends from from the United Kingdom so
it'll be interesting to see them them in
action here today yeah I'm not sure if
this is accurate but I'm hearing
something I'm reading something about
slight technical issues that game could
be starting in about um ten minutes
maybe yeah well we can fill the time
yeah as always I think last week we're
actually streaming on Twitch but this
week we're back on our YouTube channel
we are reading the chat Matteo and if
you guys have any questions for us we'll
be be happy to answer it's great to see
you guys all here ready to go I think
it's gonna be an exciting match today
yeah it's um I feel like last week when
we were facing that um we're at I mean
it could have been a little bit worried
er alright say you know Gawain Jones a
legendary player of course but not quite
on the level of a coruña Kumar is
internet chess and speed chess in
particular but that being said of course
last week we had Fabi and this week with
Nicolas we're not going to be favored in
quite as many matches but I think we
still are very much the definite
favourites two women actually I don't
really know much about the their boards
three and four so if it indeed have this
ten minutes we could take a little time
to look these guys up sure of course
boards three and four from the UK lions
being max Burke tanned brighter and
Marcus Harvey
knows who knows who these people are and
what they're doing in life that's a very
strong chess players I'm sure fun fact
my brother does live in UK so if he were
here he could maybe give us some insight
but going into the show all right let's
see yeah and of course one more time so
they're going to be 16 games spread over
four rounds today and we'll be covering
all of the rounds hopefully barring any
controversy but eight and a half points
to win the match so I'm very much
expecting the st. most our traditions to
do that of course they will too but I
mean honestly I would feel more
comfortable as if me was playing well
it's with Bobby playing it's almost like
inconceivable that you can they're gonna
score enough points against Bobby and
then Wesley and Liam Lee but without
Bobby on the team we still very much
have a deep roster Nicolas theodora like
me said one of the strongest
international masters in the world and
also a bit of a speech at chess
specialist it if I if I could say so
he's very experienced in the protest
League he was a part of the World
Championship winning Archbishop's the
past couple years and you know I've
actually had the chance to play him
personally and it was not a fun game
well when I played to him in the aspect
of Saturday's special sometimes during
last last season yeah I had a pretty fun
game oh I was Wow interesting
that's why you're on the roster too I
guess thank you thank you but he was he
didn't have the upper hand most of the
game but I came up with some nice ideas
and I thought it was some some sort of
four nights he was white yeah yeah I
ended up with a pretty neat attack I'm
I wish I had that game so yeah well
correct me if I'm wrong but something
that struck me about the way Nicholas
Theodore who plays speed chests as he
seems to be one of those players with
the uncanny ability to just play moves
in any position right there's there can
be incredibly complex positions where it
seems like you have to calculate and
calculate and calculate and I think a
lot of players tend to move a bit slower
in those they freeze up but my
impression of Nicholas is that he he's
just able to play the moves that need to
be played you know the game flowing keep
the game moving keep the pressure on the
clock as well as on the board and I
think that's that's a really powerful
asset yeah I personally do remember a
sometime trouble pretty early on in the
game but ya know I feel like he plays a
very logical chess so instead of just
sitting there and calculating so many
moves he tries to like eliminate it and
all those thing that I'm trying to teach
and nitrous and psychology class
he's already mastered oh yeah yeah he
does give the impression that he always
has things under control even when he
very much does it
which is psychologically I think that's
a powerful and that is true I'm pretty
sure I thought up until last move that I
was like my better what does he have why
is he looking so happy yes no he just
he's very stoic we have to read also
from what I understood he is studying he
has like all science classes this
semester so I I will see how he fit
chess in his very busy schedule yeah
that's it that's a huge struggle for I
think a lot of collegiate players as
collegiate chess is growing in the
states here and especially in Missouri I
guess more and more very very strong
chess players are coming to these
schools but these schools are no joke
right yes just spend a lot of time
studying spend a lot of time focusing on
schoolwork as well as furthering your
chess career yeah that is true well
today is the first day of school so we
get to skip back yes all right
so still waiting for these games to get
together I don't really have any updates
on how about the them hopefully the
delay
not so delay anymore I am but yeah the
latest updates I had is about two
technical issues so once again thank you
guys so much for joining us in YouTube
chat we are gonna get going here pretty
quickly we are just waiting on the
players for their games to start so no
no rushing these things sometimes well
why don't we take a look at some of the
other standings and very big here so
like I said there are two teams that are
a point ahead of us so far and that is
the Argentina
Krakens as well as the Chicago wins and
of course we had the wonderful st. Louis
Archbishop's manager might come around
last week and he was saying he thinks
that the Chicago win team is really the
team to look out for for us in this
division yeah yeah it's I agree I was
trying to come up with something more
powerful than my agree bus so yeah yeah
as Mike was saying last week you had the
very very strong Webster windmills in
the in the previous season and I think
another very strong Chicago team as well
and they've kind of been combined into
this one team called the Chicago and I
see a lot of corns and previous Webster
guys that means they have players like
Ray Robson players like iliena Schneck
players like Alexander siminoff and yet
case out of Perez is also playing around
the Cobian and of course the the
youngster Andrew Tang is also on the
show interesting
so Andrew tang of course you know an
internet chess aficionado everybody
knows I think he does quite a bit live
streaming these days and it plays a lot
of speech that's breaking raining
records on across multiple websites so
hope you wanted to look out for yeah I
feel like this well I mean why didn't
they just call this thing that Webster
something about that sir I mean well
yeah I don't know the details
yeah it's they're interesting to me it's
all of them seemed to have been at some
part of their life in their stir
yeah and of course the Argentine Krakens
was a bit of a surprise to see topping
the leaderboard after round 1 they do
have some very strong players but one
name that sticks out for me is of course
better Rico Perez Palma Ceia he's you
know been been around the scene for
quite a while now and they also have a
couple other grandmasters Ellen I don't
know how to say that last name Thank You
Co Picon I don't know
and do Flores as well as some
international masters rounding out that
team as well but definitely the team I'm
looking out for is the Chicago wind and
then lastly the other winner from week
one is the undeniable Canada chess brahs
team they have some very devastating
players like Russia Giri Perugia all
topping off their their roster yeah I I
personally think this might be the team
to look out for I mean yeah we will
definitely have a have a hard time well
harder time facing them rather than
Chicago webster's yeah yeah this
definitely looks like like a roster to
be aware of although it is worth noting
that's Richard Gary Frazier and even
Robin van Campen are all actually free
agents
oh so I think that means is that you can
only play one free agents at her match I
might ask you two could be two in two
but that does mean we're never gonna
face all four of them you know it's Kris
sure Gary Persia and then are the RB
kale on the same Oh interesting
so two of the I'm gonna call them
Pershing blood because um theorist
repression blood and I think I saw
Orient are you or are you entire also it
was interesting so so yeah definitely
some teams to look out for in our
division here Tommy Envy
be honest we have so much sleep papiano
yeah no morning is I I really I really
do think we're the favorite against any
of these teams this is me sugar go watch
their comments or even talk about us
yeah I'm willing to bet a lot of these
teams are looking to us to be to be the
trophy especially of course defending
champions of the process League yeah I
talked to uh to knock us out um I'm
still kind of waiting for updates over
the games to begin definitely maybe why
don't we actually
oh thanks something start right the
games are starting we have Dominguez
facing Marcus Harvey Wesley so playing
max Burton brighter Liam we like John
Spielman and of course Nikolas Theodora
against going Jones so which game do you
want to jump let's go by racing from our
side
so yes Letty a of course yeah one for us
Selenia has black facing their board for
Marcus Harvey yes so Ritchie opening but
it doesn't look like the usual ready I
mean unless why it's trying to play d4
then this would be transposed to I want
to say super toward but alright
nevermind
yes something in that nature but we do
see black go for an early in b6 and
Bishop d7 yeah which sometimes is is not
you know the most advisable thing to do
quite so early in the opening but since
white kind of took a more passive
approach to the center with Knight f3
and B 3 omission V 2 there's plenty of
time to do this and now with d4
why is looking to keep the pawn on d5
keeping that light squared Bishop out of
the game and so
black probably gonna be playing moves
like c5 probably gonna be looking to
open up the center a little yeah yeah I
was gonna say some of the moves that are
very common to be played in this
situation is well the Knights to be poor
black tonight to put in e4 not right now
but to try to do that
well definitely both sides are gonna do
short Castle and if there's a nice efore
then you could try to support it more
with the 92 f6 or even with something
like Queenie 7 yeah coordinating the
pieces and what Bishop on b7 seems a
little bit stuck behind the D pawn it
does support this eve force where I
agree I feel like Black has a very nice
start
yeah I don't think there's any real
problems for black yeah of course you
see a 6 preventing any annoying 95°
hitting the bishop in the pawn and I
think this is gonna be a comfortable
game for lineage I think so too he's
just have it's alright what's associate
find himself in the midst of I guess
smash be right here iy5 is as dangerous
I'm sorry I
I mean it's neither so yeah I mean these
top players although all know they're
not exactly
neither of some berlin's it's like their
breakfast yeah so I'm not very familiar
with this line but I mean I've seen
games but I haven't done personal
analysis but um
Thank You fire it seems very interesting
to it Wesley seems to be spending some
time here which is a little bit
concerning but as long as he's solving
solving the problems that White's posing
I think he'll be doing okay well one
thing is that this ePHI pond could be in
trouble sooner or later
yeah already it seems to be under threat
due to something like Bishop takes g2 in
Knight takes e5 but it does have to be a
little bit worried about some knight c6
check I agree I mean if they're if what
if white could put some peace in d6 that
would be an incredible outpost and
that's would be very scary for Vesely
but right now I don't think I think it's
it's a very feisty game I'm gonna call
it that I don't know I actually kind of
like White's position here I think a
rook might come to f1 and then there's
always threats of vert takes f7 to be be
aware I'm sure there's also some knight
of five sacrifices and in some positions
right bringing this G pawn to f5 and
then moves like have six and e 6 to open
things up and one thing that I've
noticed the high tap it really happens a
lot when there is a huge rating app like
here this Li is about 300 trading more
something that happens is sometimes even
though the higher the player gets into
worse seemingly worse position right
it's not easy for the opponent's to find
thick the concrete moves yes and I mean
it's very tough to to actually knock out
these top players yeah sometimes they do
find themselves in unfortunate positions
but they are so resourceful and so
talented but they just always seem to
weasel their way out I feel like if this
was a classical game with with a lot of
time to think for white I would um maybe
be worried yeah and we do actually see
Rick HF one here like I said some
threats of a vertex of seven some
threats maybe even of Knight a5 aiming
for that d6 square but I think it's
still under control for Wesley but that
being said how do you organize your
pieces
only this night on h7 he doesn't leave a
great impression you might want to play
Knight g5 but then simply h4 and the
Knights going to have to move again I
mean I I feel like ideally if you could
get if you could make the c3 Knight to
be relocated chorus so we see her kc8
potentially summer takes c3 ideas but
but probably just just a b4 and
mushrooms
yeah the idea that I had was to do
something like 95 and then you want to
either place and my queen e4 and
exchange the Queen's off and use your
putter pawn structure in the endgame or
you could do 94 and then maybe the other
knights got to go to c5 and I feel like
if something like that happens it's
black boots have such a strong center um
in fact 95 for black I might actually be
a threat right because then after before
the then I don't see 3 would have no
squares would have to go back to be one
yeah Wow
oh well and we see a tactic I suppose
Knight d5 which is going to be used in
combination with a Knight f5 minute so
cape like Queen takes d5 Knight f5 will
come winning the Queen and if you play
he takes d5 Knight f5 will still come
and the King will have to move and this
is actually this is dangerous
yeah I think this tactic is working just
a little bit concerning all right let's
think of us yeah I guess PIM jaegar yeah
you can't capture this Knight yeah the
fight would be too powerful things a
guard listen of the way you you capture
it well the main problem is if the
Knight f5 was played then regardless
over your king rose and next one was
like d6 attacking the Queen and f7 pause
oh I have a big question here rook takes
f7 I think this is the only way of her
for white to justify this but I think if
it's working then then Wesley's just
going to be dead lost can we take this
rook on f7
what if Queens the
Rick takes us 7 Queen d5 you're saying
yeah interesting I just I'm just
shooting moves right now yeah I thought
maybe there's there's a Knight f5 move
hitting hitting a lot of pieces we need
five there's Ricky seven Scheck can get
my rook rook D takes D seven it's
looking dangerous yes it is um I think
though after Rick f7 maybe I can play
King f7 right and if you check me I'll
play Knight hf6 and give some material
back yeah let's try and try and survive
that sounds very logical
I mean blacks pieces do seem quite
uncoordinated but well yeah this game is
looking to be quite complex so Rick
takes f7 definitely moved to consider I
think it might be good for white but
it's simply Queen f3 instead and I mean
not not to give our opponents too much
praise but I like this approach from
like yeah I don't go all lane against
Wesley so you just play Queen of three
you know you have a good position it's
why it's quite um quite concerning
because how well you fight very very
quickly I was actually thinking Knight
g5 my righteous knight f6 Knight of 6
and then uh the Queen on b7 false of
course 95 defends the Queen on b7 and
the pawn on f7 you are moving both both
threats well now the question is what
does white want because if you give me
one more move I I will take your d5
Knight or just play Knight g5 and dent a
pic on d5 so maybe what I I don't know
if not Queen F Street doesn't seem like
a nice move to me you know night if 95
didn't exist Queen f3 might be fantastic
but now that 95 is on the board it seems
as though
Wesley has this back under control yeah
well why don't we let them think about
this for a while are you two more games
we haven't seen yet this one between
lammle and John Spielman it looks as
though white has a nice central it's
really nice this looks like a caro-kann
gone yeah very wrong so there's there's
pressure on the C file actually the c6
pawn is looking a bit weak there's still
pressure on the Kings side for white as
well
I very much like Liam least chances in
this game yeah um just took very quick
looking opening it was indeed caro-kann
and the super classical ones well yeah
the thing I'm always very fond of this
carbon structure as well for whites
right
yes I'm opposed I feel like I understand
caro-kann more than French again it
depends but I just simply have a very
good result but yeah yeah this seems
very interesting because whoa like I've
seen a lot of ideas with Lucas tree but
since black played Turkish six I guess
it makes sense for shorts Castle so I've
always been under the opinion that these
structures are usually kind of favorable
for black when you white trades off this
many bishops because with the
LightSquared Bishop GOG there's not as
much pressure on the Kings side now the
dark squared bishop gone there's not as
much pressure against a you know the d6
square the c5 square things like things
of this nature
they're black so in my opinion I thought
this would turn out okay for black but
obviously Liam Leah's has done something
quite quite well well the thing is white
has a very nice floor full of mover
moves when black has to still keep
thinking about where to place the pieces
like what are you gonna do with this
Bishop yeah simply Bishop e7
stay humble then you know curl up in
your chair lo okay yeah but then what
are you going to put the king just King
F face I assume oh yeah I think well
I'll play like rook c8 and c5 and King
f8 that's what they did actually pretty
much yeah I mean you see these are
pretty much simple moves because
something like c4 you're gonna do it
sooner or later so desert sword I feel
like these are very simple moves and
even though you're giving up the d5
score is what you are you have such a
nice pace and I don't know this is kind
of my kind of position as White's I mean
don't get me wrong I would much prefer
to have control of d5 score as well
right but yeah I just feel like White
has a better peace coordination and the
better space and better like more clear
plan okay so yeah let's catch up to the
current position here so they did a
bunch of maneuvers they ah maybe they
were going for a petition almost well
yeah I think we Emily is the one to
decline it actually empty to move so as
black here the only real break you can
consider is c5 and with the placement of
the white knights that's really never
going to happen here so black is kind of
just sitting back and I think we Emily
is deciding if he wants to play for more
of course Lili is actually our board
three and John Spielman is their board
too so a draw here and you know on paper
isn't a bad result for us but our board
3 is so strong that I think he would
like to win this game yes and there's
also he's white there is a huge rating
app and he he has a very good position
he has he has better chances I'm going
to call it like that yeah
Jon Noah I think there's some pressure
on the D pawn now
with one of the night's turn it off the
board this this dark square bishop is
controlling the knight on e4 the best
that I can
I'm not so sure this should be a ton
really Emily anymore yeah I agree it's
still I feel like both sides are kind of
comfortable white might have more ideas
but realistically I agree it should be
about about the same all right and then
let's check on Nicholas Theodore ooh our
board for and how is he doing against
going Jones their actual board one I
mean seems seems like he is a pop yeah
my math is correct this week we have an
extra a pawn but this pawn on c5 could
become dangerous if it's allowed to roam
roam free
like I said why not Knight see yeah
that's what I was just thinking about if
next e4 doesn't lose tactically then I
think that's definitely the move to be
played here but it does look a little
bit shaky allowing a you know so many
pieces attacking e4 and things like that
but I don't see the tactic so I think 94
is a great move I mean if you place the
Knights on c4 another night on e5 this
is just really really yeah once once the
night lanes on e5 the knight will land
on c6 and once the night lands on c6 the
game is it's pretty much oh maybe if not
maybe Knight to c4 there could be like
this queen h3 so well yeah threatening
some some some checkmates on the back
break yeah alright let's see six instead
I think the next few moves are really
gonna be pivotal in this game here I
think King g2 would be a good move for
light like like you said keep Queen Age
there is this is very serious threat so
we just play Kings you to take our time
play Knight c4 play 95 I think the game
is well within Nicholas's grasp yeah
he's not play king g2 unless there's a
cool tactic that I don't see which side
down well
that's mercy sakes I don't know about
this move
so h6 from black was I think designed to
prevent any Knight g5 moves and now
Queen g4 is is hitting the e pawn and
I'm not convinced this is this is what
we wanted
we're not convinced at all
so there's rook takes c5 and I guess
this was the point of Nicholas's play
but then mighty for ya 94 would be a
problem but you know I suppose where
we're trading off some ponds and the
draw would be a great result for us here
this is by far the lowest rate of player
on our team which at 25 50 is saying
something but he's up against the UK
lions board number one so a draw for our
board for against their board one would
be very very nice that being said let's
take a look back it is those game is is
developing Wow let's let's actually
catch back up we were at screen up
straight nights c5 nice e5 and Wow
before it was an interesting choice but
now so Queen 65 isn't quite right due to
Queen takes f7 instead we see 95
defending the f7 square and hitting the
Queen on f3 Knight f6 check yes a lot of
tactics happening we have to take this
Queen takes now hits the rook end of the
night so black is momentarily spotlight
we regain it yeah you have to move there
okay each town seems like the reasonable
place I had those blind fun fact I think
castles is legal there it's not good for
legal that is true Rick age 7 and then
oh wait actually there was a king e8 to
King G 17 years ah nevermind past years
definitely illegal
okay yeah I forgive someone take on c5
Queen e7 wanting to trade off to Queens
and you if you don't trade off the
Queen's then I'll take your c5 pawn so
you kind of have to do it so the good
news for Wesley here he is technically
down upon but I
this is gonna be a favorable end game
for black white has made a lot of
weaknesses trying to do this you know
attack down down the F file ie five is
going to be weak even G 4 is going to be
weak c6 I think it is eventually going
to be lost to the cause although Wesley
will have to spend some time to actually
pick up this pawn yeah and so I think
this is going to be going to be
favorable let's see how it progress
really quickly so this the defendant
opponent isacs it was just trying to
open up the real punch 7 but upon a
thousand let him get away with it easily
G sixes is giving up this cheap on but
in the hopes of of creating some more
weaknesses in particular if it lands on
f6 you'll see it hits this g6 and e6 I
agree so yeah the rook didn't it go to
f3 or catch v the attacking a v breaking
one defending it 95 defining li6 ya know
wow wow wow Rick f1 gives up the e pawn
in hopes that Rick f7 is enough
compensation but I think now Wesley is I
think it's fine right I think was unless
I'm missing something terribly yeah Rick
d1 you simply play up d5 no discoveries
c4 is covered so there's no kicking this
rook away and now once we take this oh
yeah I think the game's on it well
really it has the flap John Stillman I
thought she was more comfortable when we
were looking at the game what is it I
think they were somewhere around here
Queen f3 so black got impatient of
course you know c5 is the break for
black if it's good but here it seems
that it didn't quite work out
so you vertex D to Queen c7
it's a couple paw well I simply 96 and
f7 has attacked Soraka fates see stops
no hands no we're starting to see
how the cards fell yeah exactly another
another thing that really happens a lot
when between when there's like a huge
rating app 200-300 between players is
one of them gets impatience right we
usually and yeah they try to open up the
position or create more chances and it
looks as though someone tried a tactic
here trying to pin the night but after a
d8 why is simply up a piece and and will
be winning the game I agree yeah
this is how they game in the next level
yeah all right so that's a YES for the
archbishop's yeah let's take another I
kind of want to take another look at
Dominguez this game just to see um yeah
I will say briefly it looks as though
Wesleyan solved all of his problems so
he just ruins in an end game Oh awesome
erupts just one pawn but enough he's
gonna be pawns up yeah he's also wait
yeah I'm expecting rip takes c6 and then
Knight takes h4 and then maybe simply
King d5 very very active King and plenty
of targets to look for this is gonna be
a winning in game yeah he's also two
minutes up yes okay so I'm calling that
one a win for us play don't jinx it and
then what other games
yeah I was like look at Dominguez this
game it looks like a more comfortable in
Game four I want to say black B just
because yeah this pawn on h4 is it's
kind of stunting something the white
Kings side yeah that being said the time
is not so much in our favor here in this
game yes Ward 4 from the UK lions is
really putting up a strong showing
against letting a our board won in this
match I read this looks good and now now
the white rook is getting so seconds
this okay Lydia has done this before in
fact you know I I seem to recall he's of
course playing the st. Louis rapid and
blitz the lead over the border and I
think he kind of made a habit of being
down two seconds on his clock but a true
professional he was completely stoic you
know you couldn't
even like if you just looked at the
space you would think again and now
we're on the clock I'm whatever I'm
going in temp - boy still shaking a
little bit I think most people do I
certainly do but Lenny is a true chest
professional and you'll never see him
break so bish 57 is forced if you take
these exchanges earlier but at this
point I agree it should be him
yeah I expect to see King c7 King decent
yeah and then all the weaknesses are
defended for both sides no path of entry
for either King and this game will be
over so that's a great result for the UK
Lions though
Marcus Harvey their board for drawing
money a our board one that being said
though we do already have a slight lead
in the match thanks to Lee and Lee on
board three and Leslie so well and
hopefully Wesley so hmm yeah Wesley's
gonna win this reckon ah wait a sec what
happens
DeMarcus just blunder upon not
necessarily he kind of gave up a c5 okay
but I mean if you is this I mean this
isn't really a winning attempt though
there's no a fancier way of making it
your I suppose both Kings are close
enough to the past pause yeah exactly
not uncomfortably that me said but very
commendable bye bye markets trying to
take advantage of the the time advantage
creating complications wherever wherever
possible I don't think I would do that
to his wife because even though it's
cruising complications it's still pretty
simple and I'm not sure this interest
White's really ever in any danger here
oh wow the d5 pawn is on a light square
and so that's that's really the only
target oh yeah
mmm interestingly Dominguez just decline
the draw interesting but sometimes in
these online matches you just don't see
the draw for to quickly and adjust
automatically declines but I think this
one is going to be a very very simple
draw so why don't we check back in on
Nikolas Fyodor
Wow has two knights against a knight and
a bishop and all the pawns on one side
of the board this one feels like it
should be a draw as well but definitely
there's a lot of chess to be played here
compared to Wesley so again I agree um
because the last time I checked oh we
have another result this is so just
officially one yes he has defeated his
opponents max Burke and brighter in the
second game as we expected this was a
very very interesting game though of
course max putting up quite a lot of
difficulties for Wesley potential
sacrifices in the air but Leslie
navigated the complications in a classic
natori style transposed into or not
transpose but simplified into a winning
end game and and managed to convert we
also have another result they are board
Juan Dominguez deep draw in this
position which was expected results so
you have we already have two and a half
points so in this round we have one well
why why don't we take a look at this
game both players in some time pressure
Nicolas in a little bit of a deeper time
pressure but I think this one should be
should be in hand still although this is
the type of end game where things could
can still go wrong yeah it feels a
little like he's suffocating yes luckily
you know the knight of h2 keeps the King
out of f3 and now this King is making
his way back to to the Kings side where
it can hopefully defend these ponds and
prevents prevent any any disastrous I
agree I mean I would prefer to be black
in this position yeah Bishop's are
powerful pieces like well yeah maybe
things maybe things are looking up for
Nicholas no I mean you know he's putting
on some pressure here of course f-five
being on a light square means that only
the night for black kid can defend this
pawn in the king as well
93 there's 94 Jack hopes here careful
yeah I need five instead with a similar
idea I think he just wants to put some
pressure
where is he trying to go up for I think
he's just stopping at any any potential
breakers and Nicolas no approaching
equality on the on the clock which is
good news can eat ooh and I think we
might we might see a repetition pretty
soon here I don't think he's in any real
danger of losing this game and so it's
just a question of how long who ain't
wants this wants to try
once I
oh yeah that's almost like you're not
actually sliced move to f2 is actually
under under threat but now I think we
might see ah okay so he's he's attacking
f5 in response to the threat to f2 as
their official b7 and now I think we're
actually gonna see all the pawns get get
liquidated it was their Bishop e7 I
think I just you could just move the
Knights but then there might be a king
and now the last parts are being removed
from the board after Bishop e8 and
Bishop takes g3 this will be a draw it's
not official yet but ok g4 is a bit
silly this one of course the bishop more
than enough to stop the pun
ok I want to ask why are they continuing
alright it's good
well sometimes you know when you're so
long on the clock you don't want to risk
trying to find the draw button yeah I
think something so you just let your
opponent take your phone and call it a
day
alright this was this was good result
the world a good first rounds the upsets
of the round of course
Liam Lee our board 3 defeating the UK
lines board to John Spielman
and then actually surprisingly the board
fours and the board ones both ended up
in drawn games not something you see
very often here so mark is Harvey you
really getting it done from UK lions and
Nicolas via door holding his own onions
going Jones one of the UK I think the UK
top player right now and uh very
interesting to see maybe David hell is
above him that's nice is lean yeah you
know those two of course at the top of
the UK chest for for quite a while now
so that brings our score to three to one
in our favor
and of course eight and a half is the
magic number we get eight and a half
points we will win the match and go home
with 10 extra points in the league
standings
we have a three of it's already yeah
already at three points were there any
key moments you wanted to go back over
and this and this I we never got to look
at the opening so we could take a brief
look at us
of course Nicholas and of course there
would be bonanni well yes coming up and
so we see this v6 line from light which
is not fully accepting the gambit
instead hoping to make the black piece
and slightly awkward well I mean if you
take you can do except the gambit it's a
lot of hassle honestly because it just
helped it really helps your opponent
develop yeah very quickly and I don't
know I'm a purist the bank goes bad I'm
gonna take all your puns I'm going the
game but basics of course a very
respectable line this is one of one of
the main problems with the Banco I think
actually is you know bike doesn't really
get what he once here like has to play
this instead of this awkward opening
yeah and have all the open lines and
that's what Nicholas chose to go with
here today uh I mean I agree this is
definitely looks more comfortable for
white what knows what they're doing okay
yep the bishop the pawn is definitely
coming to before and it's just a matter
of time before there is going to be a
bishop be too soon I hope thank you we
do see black getting develops all the
pieces have found their squares but
notably white is also complete completed
development yeah and so no real problems
for white here at all really nothing to
attack for black even and so white
simply has the open file with the rook
on c2 it's easier easier play I agree
this is this seems comfortable enough
for both side but I would say white is
slightly more comfortable
yeah just with the central space and the
bishop on d4 centralized and the rooks
coming together notably I think that the
Queen doesn't have a very good square
for black and this is one of the main
problems yes I agree
um yeah well the Queen comes to aid
actually to bring this other reckon
again interesting well earlier when the
Queen was a still and even I was
thinking about maybe Queen I won uh it
makes a bit more sense for white than
black though you get this battery on the
on the long diagonal I agree this is
interesting
yeah oh well interesting finding it
quite early on actually I mean he felt I
probably he saw that he has opportunity
this is a pawn with this York a 6-under
k7 maneuver wow this is quite
interesting see the Queen doesn't really
have anywhere to go so you kind of do
have to play rook c8 yeah work see
aiming to get two ropes for the Queen
yeah I think Nicholas actually declines
it was pretty cool yeah he did and he
just took the pawn and I think this is a
position you started looking at when we
were thinking about maybe cream G - but
- please yeah keep drinking sakes and
this Rick c6 I think this is really
where his chances kind of died down yeah
I think you saw him - see you Paul I
would have liked to see King G - but of
course we're very very happy about a
draw here I agree
well the thing is if Kim G - out if they
still whoops well where were we I was
trying to say something like um so I was
what I was trying to say is here is if
he did pie King G - if black plays Queen
g4 there's always they could be this a
stream yeah I think h3 is working there
yeah kicking the Queen away so you don't
have time to catch
exactly for my son that might have been
the more precise yeah way to go so I
think it's a missed opportunities in
this game made me for Nicholas but like
like we said very happy with the draw
for our board for playing their board
one and so this game I guess just just
kind of fizzled out into the drawn end
game that we were looking at at the end
of the round but why don't we actually
take a look at our pairings for round
two if they get underway here see who
we're up against of course in the first
round it's it's kind of totally totally
mismatched board one plays board for but
in the coming rounds we'll start to see
some more level matchups so now we have
Gawain Jones playing our board three
Liam Lee John Spielman gets his chance
against Nicholas Theodore room our board
for Lenny a dominguez is up against max
Berkman brighter and Wesley so plays
Marcus Harvey
of course Marcus Harvey you really put
the pressure on Lenny a few bears drown
there Lenny had done it just a few
seconds do you have a green starting
yeah better minds looks like a round is
ready to get underway and why don't we
check out and see so saw is playing
Marcus but I see that his connection
seems to be kind of shaky or something
like that
I hope disaster of course Wesley playing
from from tata steel maybe he's got some
hotel internet issues
again what aren't they what do you know
about the rules if we've his connection
is bad or something
Oh still I think the game just just
stands I think is I think the time will
just run off his clock I don't think
he's gonna get forfeited but definitely
if he doesn't connect I think we're in
trouble
alright this game is making me nervous
all right let's just click off this one
see see the other players are actually a
loose house our board one dude oh right
so Nicholas Theodore our board for
against John Steele huh surprisingly
there's London the UK Lions play
a loan system from well perhaps it it
fits right yeah I mean this also looks
like a very comfortable opening I don't
think there's much Theory here and it's
more like you have a sense of their your
pieces are supposed to be it might be
wrong so of course this this opening the
story is that the e7 pawn right like
this is the problem for black to solve
oh it's gonna stack up on it on this
half open a file and black will
eventually have to make some decision
about what to do with this I think one
of the things that's coming for for
white well and so like really makes this
decision he wants to play e5 trading off
this we keep on for for the D pawn
perhaps and I'm not sure what the
tactical justification is here yeah what
if white just tries to capture this pawn
okay
so 95 revealing the bishop and defending
me five adequately cool so now I'm
expecting something like they should be
- or Bishop g3 and then black will
recapture this pawn on e5 and actually
have a little bit of a central advantage
have one central point that was a pretty
cute mini tactic honestly yeah kudos to
Nick solving solving this upon problem
immediately and early on hmm so 94 this
Knight aiming for 486 square could
actually be slightly awkward but I'm
thinking would it be too crazy to start
thinking about moves such as f5 yeah I
think it might be it might be early
of course both the the Queen and the
bishop can jump to this diagonal with
Queen b3 and Bishop c4 see you kind of
have to be certain I would have liked to
play a move like Bishop e6 here but
unfortunately Knight c5 yeah Oh some
problems black well I mean if if a 95 is
what worries you can you just do
something like p6 um perhaps you can I'd
be a bit wary of committing this pawn to
b6 as well about you
maybe the answer is to defend my knight
on d5 a bit more which seems impossible
I wanted to play something like Knight
ce7 like that unfortunately use the e
pawn behind ya ah thank you
36 yeah uh so obviously the still lives
here yeah that's a bit unfortunate yep
don't know what to say about this
hopefully West's think it's connected
I'm sure all star manager Mike comers is
on the case hoping to get him back in
action but last time I was playing in an
airport so that we know what's under an
understandin sub optimal conditions
playing in these these protests League
matches well I think I like Nicholas's
position I do too he's done quite well
in this opening why don't we see what's
going on on some of the other boys let's
take a look at our fort 1 Gannicus and
we have here if I can find the game
another karo as you said and seblak has
done something interesting here with h6
and g5 you don't see this too too often
in the carry the last cleric on this up
the bishops for whites were exchanged
off and white have two knights agains
and 910 bishop so this seems to be
playing more in the style of like a
French defense maybe where black is
actually playing on the Kings side and
maybe looking to Castle queenside so I
would expect to see black not play c5
quite quite so freely in this game if
that's where he's choosing to put his
King yeah but at the same time blacks
both nights and queen are zoomed in this
e5 pawn oh yeah so it's a fair point
I was thinking maybe an eventual f6 but
well that's why that's why they're very
difficult to play yeah exactly that's
why this night for white is coming to g4
to put my pressure on h6 never again
have six I I mean okay I'm talking about
I'm talking a lot about
compliance for black but to my eyes this
looks losing thank you like 94 it looks
very very powerful I don't see how you
stop it
you can't play night of four I'll simply
capture this night and play Queen age
seven you can't can't castle open thank
you for just win oh wow
wins material right Thank You portance
winning the age six point or 4k which
takes you six cents and I'll be winning
I mean looks like it but maybe you can
place them to my group she's seven if 96
and rookie trades record shades I think
there's a knight of seven there's five
yep
I'll Bishop attending for the moment I
expect now maybe we'd love to put a rock
on f3 but the second I wrote touches III
night night g3 will come would be for
maybe move like g3 here why just to
prevent night off for in anyone but if
night of for there should be some queen
of oh well yeah what I I want to play
very simply I wanna play Rick III Andrew
rock f3 + f7 will be under a lot of
pressure
why not just Queen f3 them you can do
that as well but then you know Rick g7
is defending for the moment I think I'd
much rather have a rook there and keep
my queen on d3 precipice g6 sorry the
coin on d3 looks much better and
unfortunately this piece was the same
out here so we do see g3 and then let me
a does start to expand the myth I feel
like this game should be under control I
very much like Lenny is chances here
well which game haven't we really
checked out I guess Liam Lee's game no
how is that going
it started as Sicilian oh that's it 3
huh
I grew up playing Knight c3 um not
exactly this line do ya we see an early
trade this Knight hops to c6 in the d4
and then b5 but we get rid of light
squared Bishop for white and it's quite
interesting I mean
you kind of so yeah for those curious
like it's age six is aimed at preventing
Knight g5 you love to play Bishop e6 but
95 is a problem so we're stopping that
before we get develops Oh something
interesting happened I'm sorry I have
one I hear they spit it back to ten
minutes
interesting perhaps some some
graciousness from the process League
organizers giving Leslie some time day
to get back connected I don't know the
details on how how dis connections are
dealt with actually well I have to we'll
have to wait and see on this game I
guess as long as they both get a chance
to fight that what I mean both of them
are kind of hard well you know this is
also just connected it's it's strange
happenings perhaps this is the technical
difficulties they were working out
before their own starts let's hope for
uh Wow Dominguez just progressed pretty
nicely yes so he continued pushing this
a pawn and black actually did go for
seat by and and followed it up with c4
and after p3 lineage
hoping to open some files on the
queenside get at the black king and he
also has this very annoying pressure on
really all sides of the board here yeah
this is this is so my type of game here
at the psychic here the 2nd Baron this
is yeah this is honestly is against I
call it the snake style a snake style
interesting yeah a little back and forth
never know which way yeah exactly
you're like surrounding your opponents
and like a Python
thank you yes okay a b3 and I think a
nice move I think Lenny is gonna win
this game yeah they shouldn't do the
shouldn't be much of a struggle but
there's always things happening family
only is game yeah I mean spaceship did
come to e6
what's the d5 square is very very
important and once black can it's the c5
move I hate to admit it but I kind of
like the opening that's why it played I
mean um
I am a big fan of this Bishop b5 s
overall because there's so many lines in
Sicilian when we especially neither
structure where you're just like what am
I supposed to do with this Bishop right
so it kind of it feels very satisfying I
want to say that this Bishop is knocked
out yeah you know it's it's kind of like
the I [ __ ] paired to the Benoni you
kind of just have one too many pieces
right you don't know where this Bishop
should go and so you solve that problem
first and then the rest your pieces have
very natural squares to come to it's
very easy to play yeah
the other thing is if by any chance
black does get to play d5 in the right
time that's what piece extremely nice
because two bishops European center
right so wife is kind of trying to avoid
that so this is pretty nice
coming to e3 is trying to go to d5 it
notably though this night leaving f3
means the d4 square is exact and perhaps
this was blacks idea here vessels 95 and
we do see a bishop takes d5 now I think
this this looks a bit bit more
comfortable for black yeah I mean um the
f5 square though is going to be
important and probably should be
something like you kind of have to in
this positions I feel like says White's
going to start pushing it c4 before you
kind of have to start pushing if 5f4 at
some point sooner or later wow this is
giving 6 fun I don't know how I feel
about that Nexus I'm missing a strange
strange choice
yeah it's up to my eyes I think
something that King g7 was was required
I can also play King h7 defend your pawn
understand um I mean if you play
something like in I may be King g7 might
be maybe she was worried about a five
and then ninety six but then you can
whenever a five then you can just play
ninety-seven just a long time very
strange choice from from lately why
don't we we try and get caught up here
though because I think some more
development sir so he's simply a pawn
down I'm going for Queen exchange uh
yeah but you know if Queen takes b5 then
after a b5 the C pawn is going to be a
little bit stuck on this this half-open
half open file certainly it's never
going to be any better for black black
is going to be worse but I think this
endgame isn't the worst thing that I've
ever seen in my life
yeah so Queen d2 is a nice move
I think g5 is was going to be a threat
if the Queen exchange didn't happen so
here white make sure the bishop has an
escape route as well as keeping Queens
on the board I'm expecting maybe your
xt5 now for black open to double on the
seat file and keep pressure up against
uh I can see to although bit risky five
does you'd be three so maybe you're a
bastard
yeah but honestly I feel like it's it's
got um I want to call it unnecessarily
complicated how awesome but at five
every seems pretty nice because if you
can get at four and then you're trying
to sort of like trap the bishop right uh
yeah a similar idea to the g5 maybe
keeping this bishop locked on the Kings
side would be very very identities yeah
um let's take a quick look at well we
still don't have Leslie yeah Wesley well
we don't have Leslie or Marcus nobody
nobody can act in this game
unfortunately we're good huh yep what's
the back-up to ten minutes
but the neverending game yeah why don't
we focus on the games oh wow I can use
this camp to for my game of the week
yeah this is cool I think Lynnea showing
some real real class here you know this
is really interesting I I really enjoyed
watching this um let's go to see it okay
so we were at B tree and when they this
got exchanged off you simply want to put
your rook b6 and you're just dabbling up
so this is a very interesting game a lot
of times in chess you see players have
plans on opposite sides of the board
great one players focusing on the Kings
side the other players focusing on the
Queen side but you don't see this too
often where Lin ena is actually creating
threats on both sides of the board at
the same time it's nice the idea is that
with this advantage in space the black
pieces will be less able to maneuver
back and forth in the white pieces and
so with this you know versatility with
the central control learning I should be
able to create some threats that black
will not be able to respond yeah I see
right now this mines at for a night of
six was played and this knife is even
though the ninth is not that Brickley it
work like helping in the attack I just
want to mention that I I would love for
black to play Knight takes b6 so I can
play pawn takes B 6 and then sack on a
sex and win the game but well we see in
98 so this is actually picking up the
exchange for the moment you can play
Knight 6 g7 probably Knight takes B 6
will be played in response then after a
B 6 I really think this is this is going
to be good for Lenny a
I want to say it's you thinking about it
you know I guess we're kind of committed
though if you played out of six there
still is going to be 96 yeah this is
really interesting but that's really
clear because yeah I mean let's say you
do play 97 96 eighty six seven um even
though blacks pieces are still
uncoordinated
how will you continue your attack uh
well first of all there's a Knight takes
e5 threat in the position so I do you
have to deal with that I think as far as
long-term continuing my attack it's it's
a to move right I want to play Bishop e2
I wouldn't think they should take say
six and then I want to checkmate you so
oh maybe you can't play like Bishop e2
even if an IV five there's this Bishop
b5 whoa whoa a very nasty move yeah he
takes Knight
well no I mean I simply didn't see this
movie simply don't have enough time to
consider all the moves
yeah I'm a little I don't fully
understand it though I mean pawn takes
Queen what happens taking a seven I
guess I simply have 19 g7 and I have
quite a lot of material for the Queen
and then your king side your queen side
has been completely fractured and the
king will be getting checkmated hold on
what about Queen c6 Queen C fixity I
think is exchanging often take f7 that
ends well Rick c6 poncey 6 p8 King be a
knight geez 757 Bishop takes f7 I
suppose sweet we are winning they're
like what you said you exchanged
everything and you take out 7 White has
two bishops for a bishop in the night at
the end of the day and then this
advantage on on the Kings side would be
enough to win moves like that form was
like h4 so playing six is not a real
threat what about a b6 MVC successor so
this was the other line that we were
just talking about like you said I think
Rigby it is a great move king a7 and I
think you simply take g7 you have two
rooks for the Queen you still have the
two bishops and a6 is going to be under
a lot of pressure now that the b-pawn
has been removed okay yeah I can live
with this so very classy stuff for money
Queen takes c6 not a move on my radar
perhaps not a move on Max's radar but I
think a very very strong honestly I feel
like maybe free hats few more minutes we
could have talked about it I mean I
don't think I was ever gonna consider
this move but I'll trust you on that
I'm just very impressed so 96 I was
actually I was gonna mention this man
wait c7 just wins the game though right
nice and seven you have to take it
otherwise it's checkmate in one and now
White's up a queen and the game's over
nice well this is easy okay I mean this
is a bit silly no right I mean
technically yeah but that's that's not
enough it should be to the basics I
can't think you're wrong
sorry I forgot about that part sorry I
forgive you thank you so I mean you can
just play Bishop c1 then you're up
you're up a queen for the hook after f5
is tell my students don't go crazy on
your material of night to look for crazy
mates
oh don't do so getting the bishop back
but in return white is is winning a
number of
because the visual spends the night
takes t2 I'll play rook v6 and then I
can play rook takes c6 instead of Bishop
takes
this is my feeling okay either honestly
I don't think this is what I would have
done in the game but the problem is if
you wouldn't apply Bishop f7 if you
moved your Bishop let's say Bishop c1 d1
there was always this like f5 or f6 I
think you have to saw respond with fish
about seven eight yeah
g4 is a strange move to my eyes I think
I can take that and then I'm very very
happy if you take it back okay
age four perhaps I don't understand
everything
I just like to point out that this - so
is is still Emily yeah am I not making
any progress Marcus seems to have
connected but really why don't we jump
to Nikolas theodora's game it looks like
he's in some and looks like an end game
where unfortunately things are starting
to go starting to go wrong there's
business just checkmate that's rather
unfortunate Brooke f7 unstoppable
checkmate Forge on Spielman and Nick
does go down which is a shame I think
earlier in this end game it looked to me
to just be a dead drop reversing it's
somewhere here I think so yeah we saw
some pieces get traded and I thought
this would be a very very I thought this
would be a finding game for for black he
regains his pawn and in fact regains
remember there was there were some
tactical effects that this is not an
in-game of the dictionary losing I
didn't think so too
I mean why it seems to have the better
he has a square for his name which
counts for a lot
anything yes 9 h 1 i think it's its
start of well where else did you go
wrong maybe I would just play rook b2
and leave the night there if in a moment
yeah yeah I don't know night-night h1
can't be correct yes look so fancy
honestly and then f6 as well no our
Kings pin yeah all right these are it's
easy to see how this very unfortunate
game there for us I do wanna say lenio
Dominguez has won this game against max
Birkin breader of course he played this
very nice Queen takes c6 move and at the
end of the day
checkmate has appeared where does his
route go
I think all of his irks I don't know how
so this is the night of Indiana now
white is up a queen for the rook gives
up the bishop CC this move takes you six
weeks
oh and now the very nice rook takes c6
with Bishop takes d5 oh this was a plan
all along
to get the bishop to come to to be here
to be up f7 so whenever you take on e6
and then you have this route a6
regardless cuz there's a bishop d5 yeah
very nice very nice play from for money
I hear I'm definitely showing that for
my yeah this I think this is honestly
like an incredible game yes that's one
to keep track of where the record books
well there is one more game going on and
Wesley Zoe's game which has started
Wesley has played moves okay so we're
gonna have a lot of time to talk about
that why don't we focus on Liam Lee
whose game is nearing its end I agree
oh whoa this is going to be a draw I
mean the honestly this is a good result
for us because then we are board 3 yeah
yeah unhappy with the job I mean even
though Nicholas was slightly higher
rated than spillin
Spillman is simply a more experienced
player yeah not just feelings been
around for forever and I'm pretty sure I
read some of his books yes various games
authored irritation I might be wrong but
I think one of our teammates slew chess
players
his woman is his role model or there's
Leone pressing for a window yeah no okay
there's queen bee - I didn't see this
check I thought a queen c4 was
threatened and some dangerous things
were happening but perhaps this is in
fact just going to be a draw so I expect
this game to end I mean Jude do you
think anything can happen here to make
this game not a drill
there's always blunders but I suppose so
logically it should be a drum well why
don't we leave them to work out the
details then and we can focus on the
last game of the round which got a very
very way to start but we will stick with
it this game between Wesley so and
marques Harvey so I have a question um
even though this game started later does
it mean that the next round of don't
weed started after this is I mean I I
can't imagine they would start early
because you know Marcus will have a new
opponent and mostly would have a new
opponent so that would be just half the
games that can't get started until this
game manages so perhaps after this game
we can take a short break maybe good
idea I think I think I can use it even
yeah let's do that's right after what's
going on in this position I do want to
look at the open quickly for late I mean
I certainly understand I feel like it
takes just playing French with both
sides take such a huge understanding yes
so this is the theoretical this is all
theory I mean 94 and I'm not sure if
clean before is I mean yeah it should be
but then you do have to exchange it up
and these end games simply look slightly
more comfortable for white mainly
because of the space I want to say yeah
and personal experience
I did get I wasn't very comfortable
playing against French caro-kann and
Pierre up until parameter on Nagy cake
he like had this bunch of books
published his 44 yeah he likes 2014-15 I
would say 16 and I started reading those
and surprisingly in 2014 I was about
2100 its and then I mean fluctuating
yeah and then by end of 2015 I already
have my norms and my I've crossed 2,400
oh yeah wait that was 960 sorry about
2015 I was like 23 60 70 and those dudes
really helped Wow we doing results yeah
unfortunately why unfortunately Wow the
notice isn't drug
I thought disaster instruction is ah
black had lost the pawn and I thought it
was going to go into be poor
I mean queen of the games are still
extremely tricky yeah but generally you
know in time pressure out expects that
that's a very much favored the attacking
side rather than yeah some annoying
checks and like did lose this deep on
but still managed to hold the game very
impressive from Liam Lee I agree I'm not
entirely sure
uh like Gawain Jones Mouse lips Queen B
5 check which allows the draw for black
I think this is this was simply a
winning visit its without this Queen e5
check but I mean the pond seems to be
with him in Queen and so here we see
Queen e5 a very strange move from going
Jones allowing the Queen trade and the
draw and king upon endgame but he said
it said actually that this was a mouse
leg
actually recommend a bottom he's that
that's bestest Chester County ah and so
a lucky break for Liam Lee getting this
this half point yeah what is he what did
he wanted to do just please well I think
he had picked up the Queen and then he
wanted to put it back down to move the
King but unfortunately he put it back
down on the ground square play 25 check
it's part of online chess we'll take
those half points where we can find them
and that leaves this game with West
Excel and Marcus Harvey so what score
now we have one half one and a half in
the three games as we played this round
mm-hmm so no yeah this is I think that
this is an accurate score up on the
screen here four and a half to two and a
half in our favor with this game being
the only one remaining in the second
round
honestly this this should this was
comfortable for Blatt for both sides I
want to say it but maybe um slightly
more comfortable for whites
again I think black has has done quite
well this Bishop on a three it's very
annoying piece preventing this Rick from
coming to c1 doubling on the seat file I
was thinking maybe the whites could try
to bring put something like bring the
bishop back and yes try to something
like King d1 would be natural yeah
Bishop c1 trying to evict this Bishop
but then again black black and place the
moves as well things like Knight be four
would be trading things off quite
quickly things like b5 might leave your
knight without a good square to go to
definitely a lot to consider here for
Wesley so I was thinking maybe another
idea to consider would be well yeah this
nights coming to D streets you just take
away with so many squares from the
bishop but I was also thinking maybe
something like g4 honest and some Kings
that expansion as well yeah
because White's main advantage is the
space so yeah I definitely agree to my
eyes though 94 seems to solve a lot of
problems for black here after night
before you you can obviously trade rooks
and then after it takes c8 you can't
really get away with 93 can you because
Rick's et chaque might come although
maybe maybe that is simply working so we
do see b5 this other move that I
mentioned I don't think you really want
to go in for 95 here I don't think this
is specifically since if Knight c5 there
could be this Bishop c5 d c5 d4 or
90,000 d4
right miss plum come to d4 of course
opens up the bishop on a 7 not what you
want to see from white maybe two though
there's a nice move yes but yeah then I
come into b2 is useful is now against
night before another B D yeah another
thing I was thinking about if if like
the bishop money tree and the King
Gandhi - were like switched the King on
e3 is actually pretty safe yeah as long
as you control the c3 square that's
really yeah yeah well even I mean right
now through the night on B to you as
wise you get this rooks Ewan's
depending on what's black does but yeah
interesting
so I mean night before it seems like the
next room you if I keep saying this over
and over again but in this case though I
think white can deal with it quite
effectively now if night before will
take on c8 and then play Knight B d3
we're still yes this this plan I just
said and there's no entrance for for the
black rook and I think this is this is
under control for Wesley yeah black had
some nuts on the Queen side but now I
think everything is kind of held
together send the opportunity to start
playing these moves like g4 like f5 and
expanding on the Kings side maybe
another move to think about yeah I was
thinking what if what if what black just
starts doing a force stuff because
straight now a c3 square if I mean
Bishop takes before
oh you kind of have to play Kings do you
want don't you because if King d3
there's room C for C so King d1
and I'm not sure if if that actually
causes too many concrete problems ships
III yeah I'll play rook season it seems
okay before oh well I'm going to bring
my other nights into d3 and I think your
Bishop might end up a little bit stuck
if you do commit to this before yeah
there's there could always be the Bishop
d2 exchange notably after a 5v5 is
hanging for the moment black wolves will
have to do something about this so yeah
maybe your line is actually correct
though they ship C 3 or C 1 V 4 and then
you have this idea of eventually playing
Bishop a6 if you can to get your Bishop
back into the game but it's not so easy
to achieve I'm not sure what else but I
can really do you though you can't play
Bishop a6 here keeping keeping things
under control not committing to be 4 we
reduce the in fact Bishop c3 well April
c1 you kind of I think you do have to
play before but in what do you do with
the Knights do you play like nice b8 you
know this Black Knight maybe maybe it
should come to the c6 squared via be 8
so might be a c6 but no real good home
for that night I definitely agree
you might think a fight would be a good
square but g4 is going to come from
white to always prevent that so yeah we
do see b4 committed now I don't think 93
93 was the first movie that I said I
don't think it's very good though
because Bishop a6 would be would be
possible okay
what about something simple like night
c2 would idea Bishop d2 Knights III so
I'm relocating like that but honestly it
it's it feels really hard difficult for
either sides to just make progress prove
the pieces my new plan is actually
Knight f3 I'm gonna play Knight f3 and
g4 and f5 and I want to say that black
really can't touch too many of his
pieces if you want to play Bishop a6 you
might start with a move like rook e8 but
as soon as you vacate this
file I can play move like Bishop d2 and
try and take advantage of the missing
room this is taking his time thinking
what to do here
there have about some same time but wool
yeah so we see Bishop b5 this night does
relocate to to the b8 square now maybe
Knight d3 is this idea I'm not I'm not
so sure actually I don't don't very much
like this Bishop e5 move personally I
mean where what else did you want your
Bishop to be well I wanted to put it on
d3 so I would have some ideas after
expanding on the kingside things like a
chief I you can always do that
just the Bishop on b5 is just maybe
creating a little bit of is that
questioning do you want to play in that
sistex are you ready for me to take it
otherwise I was under the impression
that black did one play knight c6 stuff
but Bishop basics is also being
supported now as well but I don't maybe
Wesley has some ideas in mind but this
this is my reasoning for not liking this
move so much I think that'd be a it's
useful for black
and yeah king of fate for black now so
simply bringing the king towards the
center although he does have to be a
little bit wary of leaving this h
pontoon far behind
yeah we've been saying for a while now
but I do think I do think G 4 is the way
to continue I don't know if your if you
agree with this but I usually fan of
getting more space yes so this bishop
does come to d3 know that the king is
left to H pawn black has to make a
decision on what to do with it age six
is possible g6 as possible but both of
those moves are creating some weaknesses
oh my f5 is powerful now and the idea is
f6 and this this H pawn might be feeling
a little bit lonely on h6 I mean I've
never so many six I think you can't have
to take it you have two tickets ah yeah
okay what's the agrees
I thought maybe Bishop b1 was playable
there was ya bish apaf-1 maybe is yeah I
mean you would if you if you wanted to
keep here the d3 bishop then you would
have to like give a lot of chances to
opponent so that's not really ideal yeah
this one prevents prevents counter play
keeps black on on the back foot and now
moves like f6 are going to start to
become dangerous I don't know if it
works immediately immediately black
might simply capture this pawn but in
the long term I think this is going to
go very nice oh yeah okay a4 taking
advantage of the temporary placement see
yeah for black's knight hey works rights
you can't just take it's because you're
C tree and the pawn is not Spadina stuff
I tend to agree also notably if the
black knight ever moves we're at exceed
is is with check Wow h5 so black is
trying to solve his problems
it's tree h3 butts the more pawns that
get traded over there on the Kings side
I think the better it is for black yeah
but see if he plays I'm like h3 and then
hght you could always try and do kinky
to your control
yeah yeah I definitely see that but
instead me see takes c6 and I think this
was the point of black pudding the
knight on c7 was that he was prepared to
me take c6 with Knight takes c6 Knight
d6 I guess yeah I don't know I somehow I
somehow I'm starting to doubt this
endgame because as soon as we commit the
rook to the G file you know play
something like g1 - mr. Bishop b2 and
the newark c3 is is going to be a bit of
a threat well maybe you can try and play
it King d3 first and then roukoz so if
you move the bishop
there's always Bishop d2 so I'm not
interesting so king d3 here that's a
that's a nice idea what they yeah but
then I King would reach in time
well now King d3 perhaps and there's a
rook F for threat or or simply rekha for
first you're defending the D pawn yeah
and attacking Jeep on if you do play
King h5 perhaps you run into rook f7 and
after king g6 rook d7 rather order like
a7 could be picking up so yeah this rep
is getting to accident shot it I am
convinced I think Wesley has this game
under control this one looking very very
nice for whites
I'm games all about activity and Wesley
managed to find the activity here
temporarily technically down upon but
the extra pawn for black is not so
useful and so we do see your fixed g4
check leaning upon so King it's 5 I
guess I mean if King gets five ripped g7
there's rook see tree getting a little
yeah there's there's also Rick g5 check
thought it's a worry about right
not sure we can get away with that so I
think Bishop d2 would make some sense
here keeping the rock out of c3
defending that b3 pawn for as long as
possible not bishops and Trey at bishops
III maybe we can allow maybe just push
up III back well then we're repeating
though Marcus is holding on here we
should see one even trying to keep
trying to force that the bishops off the
board I think white needs the dark
square Bishop stood to win this game but
that being said I'm not sure this v1 is
playable if rook c2 King d1 is a fork
somehow and the rip would have to just
simply retreat but definitely not not as
clear as I was saying moments ago I
think yeah Bishop II one they could keep
it how are we doing in the chance anyone
I've seen questions ideas some talk
about Wesley so playing and bull Tata
Steel in this event where's Wesley a
real trooper played in in an airport in
round one and I think playing from from
Tata Steel today we appreciate him
making the effort here for the st. Louis
Archbishop's you really improves their
team quite a bit I think if he wouldn't
play then who was our board I guess
because of people playing regardless but
yes because Bobby is out for this round
I'm not sure who we would who we would
choose from the roster had Wesley
decided not to play I think there is
some rumors that Julian korolenko might
have played but he's pretty far down on
the roster maybe we would have tried to
find somebody some some other
Grandmaster to play notably in this game
though we do see the bishops come off
the board
and now after rooks III rookie three and
perhaps Wesley was calculating this this
in but looks to be a draw if it takes g3
in my opinion also yeah this King comes
to g6 but no real no real entry for for
either King here I expect to get five
can get three and then maybe simply just
g5g for and completely blocks or a
second half point against our top two
boards an incredible score for the UK
Lions actually although we are still
ahead in the match definitely a strong
showing in these first two rounds I
agree this is this is quite an
interesting game
Marcus is still considering though his
various various moves here we do see
King f5 k CF 3 hoppers checking a three
the only reasonable move and then uh
[Music]
perhaps Marcus is considering trying at
King g5 and the point is of g4 there's
king h4 and if king f4 there's g5 check
and black would be winning upon but I
think simply King f2 for white is is
keeping the draw okay
G for King g2 and just moving with me
enough to ng - yeah I think that should
do it
alright I'll say king of King g4 so
Kingi to g6
yes so uh III do want to mention
actually sure so if G for King aged for
King F for g5 check if wait could play
king of five then white would actually
be winning it's just the classic I think
trebuchet position in King pong games
but if king of - King g4 from g2 and
then g5 with a very very similar looking
in game but now after king h3 it's okay
so if g5 their King up to king h3 king
of f3 it would be the same thing but
King F where B but B would be legal so
instead we see we see this
Oh what's amazing oh no I don't want to
say it but a very very accurate play
yeah what Wesley resigns and that's a
full point for marques Harvey he scored
one and a half against Wesley so and
Lenny a Dominguez that's that's crazy
who is this person well Wow yeah very
very impressive technique there look
yeah but I mean honestly Nepal and the
game looked a little suspicious to enter
yeah
but at this point he doesn't he doesn't
really have a choice so maybe this was
the point
yeah Kingdom honor I'm not sure why
Bishop a1 wasn't played I think that
looks like the more natural way to have
to keep the game III I agree because I
mean I guess Bishop h6 would have been
slightly awkward to deal with in
response to Bishop he wanted the idea
being rook c2 is coming and Roxy one is
coming if he play King do you want to
prevent it yeah
can you just play
yeah maybe maybe work out for Chuck even
would be drawing a bit more easily I
don't know it's it's it's it's a tough
position actually for Wesley tougher
than we were giving it credit for
so a very well played game by it by my I
agree there were a lot of um there were
a lot of great moments but I thought I
really thought here um oh I have it
under control
maybe this was ambitious just play a
streams see how it goes yeah maybe just
sticking with h3 but is there a plan of
improvement for it for black that's the
thing black has more tricks up his
sleeve rather than whites because why
it's only pretty much only I hope is to
get the rook and the King side and
attack the pawns from there yeah but it
doesn't feel so realistic because the b3
pawn is completely well Wiggly yeah b3
is very very weak it's undefended and
rook c3 is always going to be a threat
unless we dedicate you know our Bishop
to preventing it and then we have we
have other problems that we need to
solve with this Bishop yeah
so I guess the may be the most solid way
to go was a strain set of taking them
yeah I think I think I agree with you
there um so that being said Marcus for
me does upset Wesley so in a crazy turn
of events that brings the match scored a
four and a half to three and a half once
again eight and a half points is the
magic number we're hoping to reach but I
think we are going to take a short break
and we will rejoin you for round three
of the protest League when you visit st.
Louis you'll probably want to watch the
Cardinals for the Blues what about after
the game heading back to the hotel would
be a major
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us you guys know I
can't play this right st. Lou is always
exploring be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess Hall of Fame
in st. Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience is that you mr.
Feeny we get your autograph of course I
think it's pretty cool that you love
chess so much we love chess to enjoy
school chess program and getting me to
realize grandmaster I got this big one
time I put a police captain after school
and check my name in 27 moves Wow I
should be asking for your autographs
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis chess club org
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premiere gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
you may have heard about st. Louis's
world-class museums art history science
even magic
[Music]
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by
[Music]
this kids it is st. Loup is always
exploring anybody
[Music]
no matter your age or skill level chess
is a great game to learn and play the
same lose chess club offers affordable
memberships for families students and
individuals there's so much going on at
the club with lectures classes ladies
nights and tournaments in addition
there's always a Grand Master and
residents to help teach learn and play
come join us at the st. Louis chess club
and see what chess has to offer
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals for the
Blues what about after the game heading
back to the hotel would be a major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us you guys know I
can't play this right st. Lou is always
exploring be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the World Chess Hall of Fame
in st. Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience thank you mr. big
here autograph of course I think it's
pretty cool that you love chess so much
we love chess to enjoy school chess
program and gotta meet a real-life
Grandmaster I had this big one time I
put a police captain after school and
chick wait a min 27 moves Wow
I should be asking for your autographs
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis chess club org
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org hello
and welcome back to round three coverage
of the protest league as always my name
is Caleb Denby and I'm joined by Dorsett
Derek Shani and I don't want always too
much time here because the round is
underway so why don't we
jump right in and see what kind of
pairings well yeah let's check out the
pairings first and see what we have
going on here of course yeah John
Spielman playing Lenny a dominguez that
is our board one against their board -
Gawain Jones the UK board one is against
West's so who is somehow our board -
despite being Leslie so Liam Lee our
board three has his chance against
Marcus Harvey who has been performing
phenomenally so far with one and a half
points against our top two boards and
lastly Nicholas Theodore who is up
against max burking brighter that is our
board for against their board three so
why don't we see how the games are
progressing so far yes so ninety four
and and the point of the sacrifice is
that the knight on e4 is actually
hanging at the end of the line
[Music]
and then this knife is hanging so yes so
Queen h4 and you end up picking up this
knight on e4 so so black is a pawn to
the good but white does does still have
the bishop pair and a little bit more
central control here little tactic stats
could end up being the determining
factor in this situations exactly so
yeah I feel like I'm I'm kind of hopeful
for this game I just don't understand
why White has so much more time on this
double yeah that's very very interesting
white you know perhaps adopting the
strategy I think this is something you
see from strong players a lot when their
position starts to get bad they actually
start playing faster and more
confidently it helps a lot to at least
have some edge on the clock even if the
board isn't is it going your way yeah
let's take a quick look at the Leslie
slows game who well it looks like this
game is already in game which I think
seems to be in Wesley so his favor here
it's ruckus this was an Italian opening
and the famous these yeah they're so fun
to play yes but like everybody knows
everything about these theories so and
and so they very quickly reached this
yeah Queen this middle game I suppose
you could call it and after some more
trades yeah um I mean if I had to guess
both players wanted to play a simple
game after mmm last round
yes and some tough games last round and
so now we do reach a full rook endgame
after Bishop takes f5 yes precisely this
f5 bomb could both be a weakness and
strength so I'm not entirely sure how
this game will progress but so far I
mean blacks trying to put more pressure
and White's trying to create more
chances
and to try and push the pond yeah so I
mean I'm going for a draw
oh maybe maybe already some yes some
repetitions occurring no now trick for
you to do some wants to play for a win
just understandable giving the edge
situation they're down a point and they
need to start scoring if they're gonna
come back in this - let's take a look at
Nicholas's game he is playing I am max
Birkin Brenner maybe he is German I'm
surprised
anyways I mean his flagon yes this is
actually looking like an Nikolas type of
situation like a Nicholas type of cake
yeah we're Nicholas is attacking always
always attacking is Queens yeah so King
you to rather than Queen side castles
I'm not sure if Queens like castles was
legal the type of position where I'm
happy I've had this discussion now
there's actually a Rick h1 threat which
would win the black queen and unless
black does something about it right now
that might be the end of the game
yeah Rick h1 how do you stop it I don't
I don't see
okay let's take another look just a
little earlier to see if this was
actually a trap I mean maybe five moves
earlier yes okay so Queen h3 it seems to
have been a should know they should
takes f7 weight ins if you if you were
to capture this piece queen g6 Bishop h6
yeah I think checkmate is so you've
gotta move the King and you saved your
father and this is some domination I
think this is very unfortunate
very very unfortunate for this is the
Bishop g5 one I love it simply because I
mean it's such a simple move you could
try and keep the bishop here but like I
said before but just logically thinking
about it this is a very strong piece for
black that's holding the position
together yeah and it's also peace
allowing it takes away the last square
exactly
so Bishop g5 now the Queen feels already
being suffocated King you to perfect
well the problem is I think a long
castle is legal okay
but yeah can you two defends B yeah
exactly huh so Rick f8 Rick h1 and we do
see the Queen being picked up for white
and this should be enough to live good
after the the things we saw last round
yeah so can you play Rick g7 I guess you
kids can't play her just that I don't
know why I want it to I see yes it's
just a bit silly rift x86 would be the
move taking up yeah the other thing is
if you look g6 there could be this night
of fades and then you may be Rick it
dude she's seven there's there's a check
involved mm-hmm maybe so g6 we do see
thank you Nikolas and I have full
confidence that Nick will be able to
pick up a full point here oh let's look
at the Liam leave yeah again sorry man
the the ringer Marcus Harvey who cannot
seem to be defeated in this match so far
although this
I'm not sure what's going on here it
looks like another complicated one it
does yes the coupon for white is a
weakness but the b6 palm is going to be
weak for black and for the moment white
is a pawn to the good well how would you
keep it that's probably the main
question yeah we might see some some
pawn exchanges after something like rook
a six I think white would much rather
keep this pawn on c4 so maybe we'll just
see it working if we remove taking the
time to defend the pawn and then only
then looking to progress yeah of course
always in these end games when you're
the defending side you want to trade as
many pawns as possible and as the
attacking site you want to keep pawns on
the board more pawns on the board the
more chances you really have but now we
see Marcus looking looking to be
insistence about picking up this this
Abe the C pawn yeah
yeah ninety-seven isn't it I'm saying
what if we work c7 then those are eight
probably yeah definitely want to limit
activity at all costs and I think 97 is
the best way to go about it all right
now you start to run into some very very
serious threats on the Kings side it may
take these sixes allowed there's some g7
pawn being attacked and if the f5 Knight
gets kicked away and you'll be in
serious trouble so what what if deechi I
was thinking yeah 92 threatens 96
threatens efore yeah and it's starting
very very dangerous for black this could
be the game Liam Lee is the one to take
down the one and only
Marcus Harvey a name to remember now I
suppose he's had a very powerful
tournament so well mat-su rounds so far
two rounds tournaments but it doesn't
feel like a full tournament no it's I
think it's just a match
phrasing what am I missing so was I miss
Knight takes e4 seems seems totally fine
black I'm a bit confused why can't they
just wanted to I I do want to say though
bring him back to this game we do have a
result plenty of Dominguez has defeated
John fielding and game as well as
another result Wesley so has drawn this
game as expected against Gawain Jones so
that brings our score up to a full six
against six to four so far in this match
and that leaves us with just two points
to go yeah that's the last round game
yeah so here we have Dominguez winning
now we have six against four you only
need two and a half more and we have six
games to go exam it's seems promising
whoa this sounds like there should be
some chicks III Knight takes e4 was was
not played I wonder what the players saw
that we're missing here ninety-six
perhaps maybe efore followed by 96
creating the threat against g7 yeah or a
96 followed by a four
yeah I'm nothing so I don't think there
was much of a difference but I still
don't understand why you had to play
this III why couldn't you just play 92
before and then Wow 92 does come now and
now I think 96 and this is this is
starting to crumble for for black mm-hmm
96
I guess his idea is to counter that with
Knight takes e4 but it looks a little
suspect
perhaps we should start with the movie
fort and then Knight takes c6 creates
the threat of rotation but if e4 94 then
5 oh yeah okay but Liam leaky pretension
in true professional style I think he's
just planning to bring this came to d3
and then there's no question about
whether or not the white pawn on c4 will
be defended the King will do it
adequately nice I like this I hope you
guys under control so yeah why don't we
check back in on nicolas maduro
I'm dill up a queen still winning the
game I think the deciding factor now is
a pawn it's very very difficult for the
rook in the night so I work together to
stop a 4 a 5 a 6 a 78 in fact we do say
a 4 immediately there's a knight c3
check trying to pick up the pawn but
then Queen 88 check would yeah exactly
so in this situation he took on
yeah nice f2 was played then a 4 and a 5
not g4 check move the King 95 check yeah
King G 3 wins the tempo and now a-six
a-seven and a-eight will be ending this
game in Nicholas's favor yay
i think it's fair to call this game call
this game on my finger business see you
logical but seen stranger and stranger
things yeah I think I'd rather stick
with Liam Liam though I think this one
still has some chess left to be played
and um alright yeah we have a couple
more moves being played so after e3 king
king came house last night
yeah no King age 6 king D 3 as we
expected and now he 5 4 black is his
attempt at holding everything together
Liam Lee simply captures
ninety-five hmm interesting
your campaign c3 there's like be fine
yeah there's all these little tricks
that uh that Marcus keeps finding that
that makes things just a little bit
difficult to uh to convert but II for
some Knight takes e4 and then black
simply responds that the night takes c4
instead of the night has been drawn away
[Music]
and there's there's a check me too and
as things are becoming a bit simplified
it's starting to become clear this this
epon is going to be powerful in any
endgame we get into here with just the
Knights so black is trying to keep the
rook on the board keep some some counter
play chances alive but I think we're
about to see this upon getting will fit
rolling and that's when I would really
show so yeah here I'm expecting efore
and f4 to come very very quickly and
that's when uh that's when I think
you'll you'll be able to see that the
power of the pawns yeah they're basics
of b6 yeah it seems dependent Oh mixture
on nice Knight c4 does defend well
enough but yeah now before as I said
expect to see e5 and f4 is and once the
C pawns presence is felt that's when the
game will be nearing its end so well I
possibly be for now writes I think we
have time to play five yeah II five
before night before
rooks tea tree then you just take on d6
or this now like before might be coming
up notably lamely is very very short on
time with just six seconds left
I hadn't even been looking at the clock
oh now we see him actually pick up the
EEP on end once again Marcus is
maneuvering his way into creating some
chances here yeah if he's not a super
grandmaster
near future I don't think I know what it
says yeah you know of course we do have
a result yeah it looks as though Nick
did manage to convert this in this game
as we expect Queens are powerful rooks
and knights also powerful just just not
quite as much looking you through here
hits the night and after King f4 is this
a fork no there's 96 hitting the rookie
gaining a tempo after 96 all this nice
gaming havoc yeah repetition can we see
some repetition now King g3 brilliantly
tries to keep the game alive there's a
check and is he losing a piece oh my
goodness this is not good
yeah resigns Marcus picking up a whole
point that brings his cards two and a
half out of three against money in
dominguez Wesley so and yeah the good
news is the cracks we only need a point
and a half yeah while they need if they
want to win the match they need to score
three and a half yeah definitely the
story of the match for the UK lions is
is this board for putting up some
phenomenal numbers the definitely an
unexpected performance from Marcus
Harvey that being said though we have
such a solid team that we're picking up
enough points on this top three board
some more than make up for it and with
just a point and a half needed in the
final round I expect that that we'll be
able to get there I was kind of hoping
for like them more like 10 or 12 yeah
it's it's not the blowout victory that
we were hoping for yeah but I I think
really of course the standings in the
process League are determined by your
total match score but when you win a
match you get 10 extra points so as long
as we're consistently winning each week
I think we'll be able to come home with
a very nice seating in the playoffs
which of course is what we're aiming to
make and of course do well in
well Mallika's is playing this mystery
Marcus
so yeah that's not so interesting
Nichols is definitely a very yeah in a
progressive style well I don't want to
cause regressive but very dynamic text
icky
yeah he likes to attack yeah definitely
and while we were talking about their
board for it Nicholas was actually done
pretty well for us as well
scoring one and a half out of three
against the top three boards for the UK
lions so a good result for Nick on board
for of course you know in week one we
had liam lee on board for it which is
just obscene but Nicholas is definitely
holding his own
proving that ye he is a very valuable
member of this st. Louis Archbishop's
team here we do see the results for
round three Lenny a dominguez taking out
John Spielman on board one Wesley so
John Gawain Jones on board
- Liam Lee drawing my own actually I
think Marcus did defeat Liam Lee in this
last game here yeah and then nicolas
maduro defeating max Berkman brighter on
board for and so going into this last
round why don't we check out what the
parents are gonna be there I think this
is the one you know the players start
totally mismatched with board ones
playing board force now we have the
perfect match up with everybody playing
putting their counterpart on the other
team so board three for us is Liam Lee
playing max Burton brighter with black
board for is gonna be Marcus Harvey I
can snica list the adore for both teams
board one for both teams
Lenny a dominguez against Gawain Jones
and board - for both teams Wesley so
against John Spielman this is the final
round which will the site at all we need
one and a half points to win one point
to tie out of four remaining games I
think we can do it but side
markets sorry he continues to be too
well mrs. Drake yeah of course you know
Marcus seemingly on a very very hot
streak but even if you were to defeat
Nick in this final round I think we are
still very much favored to get to 1a now
we just need to score 50 percent on
those other three boards and we will be
walking away with a match victory so a
little a little of a cultural and non
chest talk we have a saying in Farsi
that when you say something that you
don't want it to happen
yeah the literal translation is like
bite your tongue ah well yes there is
this commentators curse you say well
yeah Nicholas hasn't some Handy's up
mcqueen and then all of a sudden
something something goes wrong lets you
know what some point yes entrust the
players yesterday no I was thinking it
came to my mind well the Persian phrase
came to my mind when we were talking
about this the mystery Marcus I'm gonna
keep calling him being like it on strike
streaked and yeah yeah and the thing
that came to my mind telling myself was
like light song yet definitely there is
there is you know the jinxing of our
changes but yeah I think I really I
really do think version of things yeah I
think we have good chances here so we
are just waiting for this final round to
get underway just one and a half points
to uh to win this match from within
eight and a half out of 16 and art I
believe I word round one was a very good
start yeah round one I believe we
started off three two one and so that
definitely gave us the edge going into
into there
I mean we don't have to should for 16 16
yeah like I said I think the approach to
this this format that we needed to take
is just walk home with eight and a half
as if you can do that consistently week
after week you're going to be doing
doing well in the Division standings yes
[Music]
okay still don't see just just waiting
for games to get underway so why don't
we take another look at that knick game
in this previous round here because that
one looks look very very interesting how
did he get such a nice position where
that Bishop takes up seven
I don't know yet you know check out
those eyes that's something we didn't
get a chance to look at I think oh this
trip so it's d4 Knight f6 is in c5 Wow
interesting
not the most common move from from max
out with the black pieces I mean thank
you please do it again but c5 was the
points and now I suppose a p5 what is
going on with this all this Benoni stuff
yeah the UK lines have seemingly been
pretty consistent across the board with
their openings actually a lot of Carroll
Khan's a lot of benoni Benko type
positions yeah it's interesting to see
it's a little Reema nuvaring of the
night here for Nicholas and then with a
central advantage I guess that's that's
how we became to find the position that
we had on the board and greet oh4 using
this nut on g3 for support threatening
an early age five putting pressure
already on the black Kings side mission
P for Bishop e2 that's what I call
normal but yeah I like this move quite a
bit from nickel yeah
this Knight on g3 is actually a very
very important piece for weight it
controls h5 and f5 and by capturing on
f3 with the Jeep on you now have an
extra pawn lever so you can play f4 f5
very very freely and start to open up
lines
true now heat the opponents tries to
kind of like lock it off but then you
got this f5 and then you took on h5 and
that's how the bishop came to keep an
eye on f7 yeah and then we're
approaching the the position that we saw
in the game right where this Queen jumps
out to h3 perhaps a little bit you know
prematurely a little bit isolated there
on the h3 and then Nick took advantage I
managed to win yeah it was a very nice
game honestly this year that seven was
pretty cool and we see this h5 move and
the rest is the pawns spend like minutes
on half thinking about the Queen each
tree look dizzy simply like yeah I guess
it's an understandable tactic to miss
doesn't have anything yeah
perhaps you missed Queen takes e4 in the
first place of course the bishop on h5
is uncapturable after Queen e4 do tour
of GA so I think Queen h3 was trying to
make a threat but in the end Bishop f7 a
very nice move for Nick to win the game
yeah so laughter Equestria takes it well
not say then I you play h5 and you're
just bringing your pieces and you're
doing this next tactic technique to the
Queen yes can you to picking up picking
up the Queen forever trapped on the h2
square there's a question in the shot
the most Venus asks them I don't know
how to say his name
yes how can it be that one side is
averaging 100 140 points higher in it
than the other side seems a bit
one-sided
aren't there any rules over the
strengths of the team so they're
actually used to be yeah historically
the protest League has always had a
reading cap for your team you had to
average out the the four players that
you played to a certain rating I don't
remember what thing goes 25 15 yeah 2500
or 25 50 I think and
so you can go over that average rating
but then you know we found some ringers
on board four who were a bit underrated
fidei around like 2000 I think and so we
play it
Fabiano and Wesley on boards 1 and 2 and
then we kind of lowered our average
rating using using that board four and
so this year they decided to mix up the
format a bit they did away with all
those rules play the best players that
you can and see who who can have the
better team feels like Hunger Games to
me yes are they all local players then
they are not actually all locals is pre
agents right so yeah you can have a
couple free agents on your team each
week either one or two free agents you
can play and they can be from anywhere
in the world but the rest of our team
actually is local with Fabiana kara
wanna being a local player wes is so
being a local player Lenny a dominguez
being a lot more question yes so
Benjamin Nicholas and Gigi they all go
to Slough and they are us they're all
residents of this state yes so that's
actually a little bit unfortunate for us
of course the the slough team members a
lot of them came to Slough from foreign
countries and their feet a federation
still is representing those countries
and that's not just common decided to
determine whether they were local or a
free agent by that that Federation so
unfortunately even though Nicholas and
like Benjamin Bach and these people are
all living in st. Louis
they're Federation still is that other
country so that's how they're being
represented here that's something they
can adjust for next yes maybe maybe
everybody will switch to the u.s.
forever that's that's how we would
prefer it here but for the moment we are
still using them as free agents I'm not
sure what is the holdup uh yeah I don't
know maybe some more technical
difficulties but hopefully this last
round will get underway without too much
more delay here
I don't know were there any other
interesting games huh we take a look at
this lenio Dominguez game against John
Spielman this was this previous round I
think mm-hmm so we saw lenio with a
pretty comfortable position out of the
opening but I don't think we saw how he
managed to turn it into yeah we were
somewhere happened here yeah this tactic
would take well saved by the round
starts yeah once again in in this final
round our board one place their board
one our board to plays their board to
it's the even the most even match up you
can you can hope for
for our final rounds and may the better
team win most insane hunger games may
the odds be ever in your favor
something like that yeah if my memory
serves it's been a while since I read
those but yeah I think Austin in middle
school or something but here we have a
Marazzi bunt for Linea Dominguez a very
comfortable opening for white an
interesting choice by a-goin Jones to go
into something like this I'm such a big
fan of this this palm structure and just
Maru see something like that nobody
knows for sure how to say that word I
just I just I've committed to Marazzi
he's gonna keep saying I'm gonna go with
Maru see which kind of drives my
roommate's crazy well you know the rule
of course yes the rule another very
strong player from from slave I don't
think she's on our roster this year so
she's a freshman I wasn't when I was a
freshman it takes a while too
yes gotta build those in this connection
but yeah I I think a comfortable open
choice but yeah this is why don't we
take a quick look around all the boards
actually and see what so what is your
prediction I would say best but since
we're not really betting what is your
prediction for these four games I like I
like Dominguez chances again
cooing Jones I think it has been playing
pretty well this match
she had that unfortunate draw in round
one against Marcus but since then I
think he's played very very well I don't
know if he's won every game but I think
he has won at least well I don't let me
actually check sure
I thought he won the other two units but
in fact he has so since that round one
draw he has won his last two rounds
expect him to continue that tradition
here in the last round Wesley so I think
it's good for at least a half point but
I'm hoping for two wins on the top two
boards and we can go home say yeah we've
won the match bring out the same thing
yes really I mean how can you not pick
Liam Lee over over max max Burton
brighter
well I'm sure max is a very very strong
player Liam Lee is Liam Lee I'm a twenty
seven hundred hundred level player was
the the crazy tactics so thank 95 and
identifies those stuff that was
happening wasn't it between Max and so
viously that was Wesley with black and I
think that was in fact max with with
white so Max has been pulling some very
very ambitious testing and see strong
players and it hasn't worked out for him
so far I think and then this last round
is anybody's guess I always like Nicolas
theodora's chances but Marcus Harvey has
been having the performance of the match
excuse me scoring two and a half points
out of three I can start top three
boards so let's see if Nick is the one
to take him down
he's a team mate he's the countryman of
my roommate
yes yeah I can't stop from Greece right
yeah yeah yeah to Greek our team's nice
pretty interesting yeah please I
wouldn't say known for their chess
players but we seem to be stealing all
the best of the best
yeah I I wanted Sevilla here that when I
when I remember when I was going to
airport's 2017 eight well I was in
Barcelona and I was going to our boats
to move here you're right
I started six things the rule and I was
like yeah you should think about that
yeah
here we are two years later she's that
flu now maybe we'll we'll see her in the
Archbishop's in the future but yet
Nikolas playing in classic Nick style
going for a King side attack caution to
the winds
let's go kill the king rookie 646 will
come launched an attack on the Kings
side I like this style of playing
against Marcus previously we've seen you
know are 27 hundredths get kind of a
slightly better position maybe go up a
pawn Nicholas
none of that let's kill the king and
again they say the thing is
unfortunately last round lammle actually
blundered yes in the end yeah they're
worth doing repetition but he's simply
blundered oh so that's why so maybe
miscalculated or something went wrong
there and the Potters game was super
easy when Ian filter 2008 like 18 under
the one that's ponens game so I mean
yeah yeah they kind of made his Marcus's
job pretty easy
it's the portion it breaks for Marcus to
be sure but nothing said I think I do
still like Nicholas's approach here I
this is what he does best
he likes going after the king I'm sorry
back to the game so the question mark
here and I clicked on it some case you
don't know it on okay but I like what
makes doing here that being said
obviously you know you know why
shouldn't be getting checkmated by force
or anything yet just I guess how is
Wesley doing against John Spielman looks
like well I'm willing to say
Wesley's up upon for the moment John
might take on me to regaining the pawn
but the story is going to be this Bishop
versus this night this night on a5 is a
horrible horrible piece and the bishop
is very strongly placed in dominating if
you give me two moves I will replace
this for probably one c1 somewhere nice
you don't start pushing before so in
addition to that also you can imagine
this trick coming to the seventh rank
when all of a sudden there's going to be
some nasty threats on f7
in fact it's Bishop f7 tactic here or is
that a way to try and lose the game I
mean I think personally I would play
rook e1 here that's enough it's the
meanest move and it also looks like
probably the best move yaps King uh P is
is the plan against this move though you
mean a kruky you wanna be one King f8 I
think is more or less forced and then
probably I would imagine something like
Queen a7 may be Queen c7 if if you can
although I guess you really can't put
those miss Kenya there's rook they were
555 event you're not quite giving
checkmate so we do see Bishop f7 the
Queen cannot capture due to the rook
being hanging so it's just two pawns
yeah no it will simply be two pawns if
we don't win so doesn't win this yeah
you like Wesley's chances for sure yes
rook c1 very very accurate stuff from
from Wesleyan not allowing John the
extra couple Tempe that come from taking
on d6 and having to remove the Bishop
from f7 so keeping the tension as strong
players often do
I think it I remember this quotes that I
remember like before I started playing
international tournaments like 2014
something right when I was reading when
I was still reading books I read about
this quote and that ang Gary said it was
something about oh well we never resolve
perfect Bob would appeal do they have
eight points yes so with that when we
actually guarantee a tie in the match
and with just a half more point in the
last three games we will be going home
victorious but yeah okay oh yeah tell
the story he said like he called it
something like if you put your pieces in
the right place they'll dance it was
something like this but it was about
pieces dancing and I always thought that
was such a cool thing to say and this
was it
right like in this situation you did put
your pieces in the good place and they
did they did the dance for you they
didn't they did all the work you put the
ship on d5 a powerful square you bring
their works to the open file and somehow
it all works out so that is a full point
for Wesley so like I said just a half
point needed to guarantee victory in
this match
how about we check in on Liam Lee this
is a game we haven't looked at yet wow
this is looking well yeah I'm this huge
central majority for Fort Lee Emily
coming down the board it's going to be
very very powerful of course white
trying to create some threats on this
long open diagonal in this Bishop on b2
but with some cautious play I expect
that Liam Lee will be just crushing here
I think work up something would be a
prudent move just depends e7 threatened
Queen takes e5 threatened things like
III just keep everything defendant I
think that I think I agree that
throughout seventh it makes so much
sense it's a sociological move I was
thinking about maybe a Queen f7 rookie
646 I was thinking or something like
that oh yeah that could be two but if
you play rack up seven you're going for
Queen c5 as well yeah the good news for
me Emily is you're in no rush
White's really not going to be creating
too much counterplay anywhere on the
board if you just keep your g7
undefended I think there's there's
nothing to worry about and you can kind
of win the game at your leisure
things like night before in 93 are going
to be devastating for the white player
in the very near future
yeah I agree this seems well enough all
right who else do you want to see me
cause well Nicholas's is really really
sticking it to you to Marcus here I
think if we catch up to the current
position he did the classic maneuver of
cutting the Queen in front of the bishop
and now Queen h2 was unstoppable and so
it was not stopped and now where's the
knockout punch for Nicholas Theodore he
plays Knight takes e4 first there's a
rook tech-support check and now how does
he want to respond to this it should be
six seems simple enough keep everything
defended and how do you bring another
piece into the attack this may be
something like Bishop d3 and then you
will be 58 and maybe some I mean what
Bishop d3 already makes the threat of
queen h1 and Queen takes g2 right yeah
in fact we're already threatening that
because the Queen on d1 is is hanging
but I expect so Bishop e6 probably
something like Knight c3 and then Bishop
g3 should be quite quite power may be a
rookie 6 works as well too but yeah I
like having this miss rook on the board
you know things like work up sticks
could come actually if I move like
Knight c3 were played yeah I agree this
is I like this Nikolas should have this
under control
but yeah yeah this is fine so who else
do we have
we already yeah
we will take a little break and let them
know this g6 move feels kind of strange
to me from a practical point of view
okay I wouldn't do it but I can't fully
understand why that's going to 700
yeah I mean Liam Liam sure has it all
under control but from the amateurs
perspective thank you this is creating
some unnecessary difficulties I agree
how queen d4 does come with some threats
of Queen h8 as well as Queen d7 whereas
before you just had to worry about
Queenie 7 but I'm sure he's got got it
all figured out ah thank uh yes the
Queen takes d5
here's Erica c1 move Queen b6 so he's
for the moment keeping an eye on the d4
square to prevent Queen d4 from coming
into play yeah that's us give this game
a little yeah all right how is Lanier do
I think this is the game that's going to
be the most interesting here
I do like líneas position but there's no
you know it's it's still kind of up in
the air what's going on here
the knight on c5 f it is on a very
strong outpost the bishop on e5 can be
kicked at any moment with f4 then we're
kind of isolating our Bishop out there
on the g6 squared I'm not sure that's
the most comfortable for us maybe one
plan is to bring this [ __ ] back to e3
play a move like Queen f2 and start to
create some threats of of taking on c5
instead we see Bishop h3 first
activating this bishop so yeah look look
for moves like g4 maybe to come to open
up this diagonal definitely not
immediately but but in the future
perhaps
what do you think on this position hmm
giving it some time nice okay Bishop g7
I don't think we want to trade these
bishops actually I like having these
bishops on the board I mean both player
I really I mean they're the strongest of
the team
well yeah and this in this match and I
owe this it really feels like they're
the the positions like they both have
some ideas and they they're both trying
to somehow open up but it's I'm not I
can't really see how yeah I think um
so for black maybe eventually b5 it is a
common break in these types of
structures something like b5 could be
one way for black to try to open things
up as for white I think he's just gonna
want to play with the pieces for a while
there's going to be some pressure along
the e file and any line and also some
ideas of trading off the dark square
bishop for the night in order to gain
control the e6 square but I think the
problem is once you do that the bishop
can kind of forever stay on f6 and
defend this one weakness on e7 and it's
going to be tough to find progress after
after that's math yeah I mean honestly
repetition is not the worst thing this
could happen yeah I would guarantee your
victory match and I'm sure Lenny a is
keeping an eye on that and knows that
I'm actually wondering so how would they
be informed about like what does it seem
need like I don't know like I mean this
is so I think that the players are all
required to join a group call program
with the chess calm organizers and I
think they're they can like ask
questions in the chat too - I think my
game they can ask things about like the
team standings perhaps all right I could
be wrong on this because like I mean
doing team turn on us you can steal it's
physically yeah you see the results in
addition to that I've been we've had
what's called like a proctor for and
historically for these players so some
watching players make sure they're
playing on generally I've done that a
couple times and for example I was in
the room with with JJ while he was
playing for us and he had all of the
games open on the side as well so he
could see how I do remember that's like
there I feel like I've seen some up like
he before like a year year and half ago
when Jenna was playing she was either I
had always liked getting picked up by
Mike and coming here or and he was I
think that was the ideal situation but I
think maybe she played in the chest room
at still too it's Alejandra watching I'm
not entirely sure but yes I was watching
the players like is that something
that's ideal by just calm yeah I'm not
sure what all all the regulations are
III think these thing is getting a
little bit switched up every every
season but Sam I'm sure there are plenty
of safeguards in place for this sort of
thing that being said we do have this
move g4 come on to the board for Linea
Dominguez he chose to open things up
yeah therefore g4 is I'm very much like
this for Lenny a I expect to see a move
f5 coming quite soon and the files
around the black King are starting to be
opens and the bishops I think are going
to be very very powerful while this
opening up is occurring I think f5
immediately it's also yeah
f5 seems like the logical continuation
if black wants to keep things closed he
has to commit to g5 which after a move
like Bishop f3 h 6h for the files are
going to become opens and I do think
that favors of the white player here
sorry excuse me
this is so interesting yeah I'm very
much like what lenio his has done with
this position yeah let's give let's get
them a little bit time I will check back
in a minute
I do want to see how is Nikolas doing
because last I saw he was supposed to be
winning dish looked winning to me and
now it looks like Black has more rooks I
think that that will be a relevant
factor oh my god King Castle I can't
believe this Nikolas a lot of what
castles of questionable legality in this
match but this was the first one think
we've actually seen yeah so come on in
Brook here he played the Chevy six Queen
f3 Bishop c7 oh wow that's not deal like
I wanted to say Bishop g3 but maybe we
should g3 was too ambitious maybe um
yeah and I think Bishop e6 is also the
threat that he was aiming for yeah on
this open diagonal Queen g1 now becomes
a very very strong threat then woo
simply castles why not this is very
interest and why not castles 54 Bishop
d5 and you see just the full control
over the board that these black bishops
really have here
this is what is is the main problem for
the white player sure that like tiny
banners Nicole s yes and so how do I can
continue with 65 yeah where do we stand
now at Queen f7 King a6 no more checks
for white so we see Queen f3 and know
how to continue we rookie 6 it's simple
enough you just want to be six as well
you just want to bring in more pieces
now the threat is Queen g1 rook takes g2
and that will be the end of the game if
allowed to happen with how can that be
stopped actually it's an excellent
question
maybe night f2 is forced 3 maybe g3 I
suppose oh yeah yeah I don't I don't
understand
I guess Queen g1 King e2 and hope for
the best
there I think now rookie 6 is a good
thing Queen H so H 3 thing I didn't even
notice I was thinking like there should
be something that's yeah yeah I mean h3
hanging is simple enough
now if Queen g2 yeah there's there's
rookie 6 yeah and this is this is
disaster for the white player I think
this just should be I I kind of don't
want to take my eye off of it because I
feel like it should be done Marcus has
worked miracles in the past three rounds
but business would be truly absurd if
we're unable to win this one I'm not
sure if alpha zero would even be able to
hold this light it would be difficult
yeah it wouldn't be difficult
well I think Lenny is actually down to
just 20 seconds on the clock so maybe we
should keep an eye on this game as
things are still progressing all right
I'm sorry you're letting a down don't do
it final seconds here but still with a
nice rise say we see the trade of the
Queen's I expect rook takes I think
although there are some merits to pawn
takes I don't think it's it's quite
right here and then probably rook g7 is
lennier's plan
Oh Bishop g4 I mean no bar look expected
he has one more pawn if my math is
correct yeah
yes then it's just probably he just
doesn't want to risk giving the pawn
back right totally understandable and
Rick F I would have hit the bishop knife
3 as long as I think maybe this is the
proof yeah just simple grace no we'll
see probably a trade of Brooks and then
I think the White King will will start
to march back into the game
and is it enough to win maybe Oh we'll
have to see
so yeah the White King comes to f3
quickly Linney a my goodness
and this is going to be a very very
tough endgame for us for black to hold a
king f4 is it sensible there's a high 93
I mean allow h5 and she's doing any
chose to commit to that
I thought Bishop a result this one
Nicholas wins so with that our match
score comes to nine and we have
officially won the match we will be
going home with Ted extra match points
for for the match victory but two games
remaining and definitely very very yeah
it's still an outstanding performance
from Marcus Harvey on 40mm UK Lions
going to and a half out of four a
positive score on board for is very very
impressive I am great uh so how do you
win this with white perhaps an A 3 B for
push is is called for just open up lines
on the Queen side the the black rook is
pretty much committed to the Kings side
here I think Lenny is repeating for a
bit to gain some time in the clock and
then I think something like Brooke b1 uh
you know he's just taking his time
there's no rush here definitely but I
think a 3 and B 4 are the ways the ways
for a white to continue this game
sounds logical but I mean you have to be
very careful with a three because does
this not be fiiied yes I wanted to play
rugby one first and then go then
continue with this opening up so look
[ __ ] let's see Lucas and Gigi are
what are you trying to do just king d4
uh I think actually I want to go king f4
and then a three and then V for all in
the next need moves where are you going
he's just getting a check checks are fun
why not
yeah no King up for and so a three
before and I'll start to roll these
pawns on the Queen side
seems like a very sensible long-term
plan and in the meantime I'm not sure
black has any source for time to play
what if something like Ethan if
something like II five years
it helps splice chances you're allowing
access to this d6 phone hello mattock
that lies on c5 looks good but it's kind
of brilliance place I know I actually
see it rerouting to it to e5 and wow the
black rook is actually completely out of
moves now this could be a very very
interesting zhulong type position I mean
there's always the King g8 well he can
play King Jaden King f8 and King G and
King f8 but I think now this Bishop is
corralling the rook entirely and and
almost entirely the Knights and so that
that gives white quite a bit of freedom
with with his remaining rook to do
whatever you need yeah should be easy to
play a treat before now uh and we do
have another result Liam Lee has this
game bring our score to know that is
winning on time actually but in a
completely winning king upon endgame
very good technique from Lee and Lee to
win this game but why don't we stick
with the final game as the players are
in severe time pressure and we do
finally see this a3 move I now see why
it is this choice to advance so this one
is untouchable
due to the hanging Knights on a five and
now perhaps before before at six
I know but the open I didn't see this
one and cilenti eight Wow
Wars they're an incredible 4-0
performance right when it counts and his
final round very interesting our score
to 11 to 5 a phenomenal performance I
think even better than our score against
in week one almost better I think no I
think was ten and a half to five and a
half last week oh yes a little bit we
are still hoping for 16 yeah hoping for
that fabled 16 out of 16 but
waiting for our in this final round it
really does help words i honestly
honestly I didn't think we would do
anything for oh but yeah I mean as we
said in this final round board one place
port 1 and port 2 place board 2 and so
on and I think it's that matchup where
we really shine the strength of your
players gets to them through we are
favored and almost I I think in every
matchup in this final round and so the
players finally proving they deserve
these high ratings and all this respects
and winning for oh and the final round
yeah I'm they're happy with the
performance and yeah this miracle thanks
what mystery mr. Marcus
maybe miracle Marcus yeah if he managed
to pull it off last round but well I'm
glad with what Nicholas did yes Nick
Nicholas did manage to to take down
Marcus with a devastating attack in the
final round here we see the final
results all forcing Lewis Archbishop's
taking down their opponents in the final
round final score of 11 to 5 for the
Archbishop's that adds 21 points with
the extra 10 for winning the match to
our Division standings and we're looking
to keep these these scores up in the
weeks to come
yeah any final thoughts for us here
dorsa I'm very glad with the this games
this round game I will definitely go
back and check that tacky game Evanier
yes and yeah I mean I enjoyed this we're
doing it again next week and whoever
playing next week nobody knows
we'll have to check the schedule for
that by all means go to protest League
calm if you're interested in checking
out the these match standings and the
upcoming schedule with that in mind some
phenomenal chess this round to
commentate thank you all so much for
joining us yeah we will join you next
Monday on Martin Luther King Day Martin
Luther King jr. Day for more coverage of
round three of the protest League here
in 2020 thank you very much have a good
day
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you